you can drive a Tesla for free see if
you've got £30,000 which is typically
about how much it costs to buy a
standard Tesla I would say don't use
that £30,000 to buy a Tesla If instead
of putting £30,000 down boom to buying a
Tesla which is just going to go down in
value instead if you use that £30,000 as
a deposit to buy a house if you know how
to buy houses smart you can rent those
houses out on Short Stay lets on Airbnb
I do this all the time if it's got 80%
occupancy it's renting out for £80 a
night that's still going to leave you
with a profit of around £1,000 a month
after all your mortgage payments your
cleaners and everything with that ,000 a
month profit you can now lease a Tesla
you can lease a Tesla from around
£425 a month so you're leasing a Tesla
but you've still got left over 500 600 a
month